[Music]
[Applause]
hey
welcome back to the break room
welcome back roomies uh broadcasting
live uh from the new rockstars break
room this is the nerdy news show that
is covering all the fun stuff that's
going on in our world that we care about
right now uh we've got updates on
netflix's geek week
deadpool 3. a lot of ob
uh obi-wan kenobi and miss marvel talk
a lot we got a lot going on today
sorry he's look at what he's doing oh
look at that what uh
i can't do it make him pay for it we're
doing all kinds of fun eyebrows speaking
of paying for it i'm i'm joined by my
great panel here
brandon barrack oh boy am i paying for
it let me tell you what it cost me six
hundred dollars a day to be on there to
be honest
hey you too could be on this panel for
six hundred dollars yes ah the wonderful
jessica clemens please help he keeps
making me see more obvious overnight yes
i think he actually likes it and plays
it off random terror will never end and
of course tommy back to old
hi everyone
[Applause]
really really glad to be here today i
hope everyone is
at home with a cozy mug of cocoa or tea
settling in for what will be
49 to 56 minutes of
nerd news
you can use but bring the camera down
yesterday
you barely
made it to two swears
okay
so what i see right now is a couple
people got an elmer's glue situation
where they glued their pockets shut
so take some rubbing alcohol loosen up
those coin purses and dump the gold on
daddy okay i want a golden shower today
all over no that's not what you think it
means
shower me with that goal we haven't even
explained what time he's talking about
so we've got our swear jar going on
today
uh we thank all the folks chatting right
now and super chatting we hit a multiple
of a hundred dollars in super chats it
unleashes our swear jar which allows one
of the hosts
to really rip with a torrent of
profanity and i will just tease
something if we hit 200 bucks the second
swear jar
is very special
something we've never done before it's a
little different i'm not going to say
anything else we'll have to get to 200
bucks we told him not to tell him
he's teetering and i'm going to say
something that i wasn't authorized to do
oh boy oh here we go if we hit 400
dollars
i'm going to take that swear jar and i'm
going to smash it on the ground and all
swears are available for the rest of the
show that's 400 and i have a feeling all
the cheap skates out there
in the break room don't have the
fortitude
i was gonna say a swear word
i don't have the balls that's not swear
words no if we reach 100 i'll say i love
you to the person that pushed us over oh
if we reach a thousand i'll come to your
house and sleep next time
oh no that's creepy
why is it creepy legally binding legally
binding could be the most erotic night
of both of our lives
let's get into the headline
uh wonderful leading off here we had
some interesting news there's been kind
of a couple little trickles about
deadpool 3 coming out
the writers of the first two movies
reese and paul wernick uh were confirmed
to return for deadpool three uh and
they've been quoted as saying that
they're gonna keep it rated r disney is
not gonna disney fi
this foul-mouthed franchise um
supposedly marvel's been very supportive
of keeping deadpool
the way deadpool has always been as
we've seen portrayed um that's
interesting also this is kind of low
keys and different
those have not been the writers that
have been talked about originally
writing this no
and
uh in 2020 they confirmed it was lizzy
and wendy bonnier the writers for boss
burgers so
moving it over means something um i
don't have anything they might still be
writers on it and they have like the
original writers to help out or like be
a part of it i don't know i have no idea
there might be five names scripts
my quarrel is uh don't bump these two
women
don't bump these to one other great ones
if you're gonna talk about it at least
give them their acknowledgements uh i
think we always constantly change
writers out for comedians that do like
rick and morty now bob's burgers they're
great people michael waldron's one of
the greatest writers right now and it's
he came from rick and morty so keep
their names i think it's good that it's
firmly back in the hands of two men
yeah we'll see hopefully we get some
news there's no uh shoot dates or
anything like that scheduled no release
date for that movie but we know it's
being worked on it keeps popping up
we'll keep everybody updated as more
news comes out we got a trailer for this
prey p-r-e-y not
pr
that's my that's my independent film
coming out in two years only on the
swank
swang one more
uh but uh this prey trailer which i i
it's not even there's not a ton to say
other than you should go watch it it's a
prequel
uh predator film yes but it's set in
like indigenous american
i think it's more about the people than
it even is about predator i think it's
more about like oh these people have
been talking years and years or a long
time about the number one hunter and
that hunter is an alien that can kill
anything
you see like this tribe uh you see the
main protagonist and there are some it
looks like uh explore i say explorers
congress awful people i don't know uh
that are there as well it's not just
this tribe so there is some sort of like
uh uh you know european influence in
this in this area too what i think was
interesting is that you see them kind of
like speaking in the comanche language
we're also speaking english which i was
like not as hot on uh but the director
uh there's another article today saying
that uh hulu's gonna put out a version
that's also entirely dubbed in the
comanche language
would be like the first time they've
kind of done that uh star wars was
translated into the navajo language but
many years after it was released and
like finding nemo had a
version that was released with the nav
whole language i believe but this one
it's gonna mostly be in english
but they will have like a dub you can
watch with the entire things in the
comanche language they hired so many
native american actors like first gen
actors and i am
clearly it looks we need to be supported
uh the adrian brodie predators from
about six yeah oh yes is a good time
it's a good time this one's gonna be
oh
we're picking that oh you do that i do
aren't you d2
i want to address some of our super
chatters already oh bray girl
i don't like you what i love
wait wait save it for me save it for me
oh sorry she asked me too okay and then
a spammer anne or spay moraine uh uh
thrown in a couple bucks funds for
tommy's golden shower
zeus courtesy of zeus flick thank you
so quick update on a piece of news from
yesterday oh look at me camera
i want to apologize about some things i
said yesterday on the break room some
problematic things things that i said
allegedly for the thor four tickets
would be dropping possibly today at 6am
you said maybe i said maybe i said maybe
a lot i said allegedly i use keywords
that any lawyer would use
and
in fact it has dropped on um numerous
places on screen rant direct uh reddit
even uh that the thrower four tickets
will drop june 13th at 00 a.m uh nope
june 9th and where the crawdad sings
june 23rd i know you care very much
about where the crawdads i gotta get my
front row seats for where they are
you and all the ladies in your mom's
book club we'll be there
but set your alarms for june 13th at 8
00 a.m especially if you're getting your
tickets through amc to get those tickets
at 8 a.m pacific oh yes but yeah
that's for us so set your alarms for 6
a.m and get out of bed you lazy
saxophone
spider jar
swear jar
i love you
kiwi sing
i love you scene oh they're running a
policy who gets it tommy oh sorry oh you
know what
tommy deserved it i think we can all
agree thank you to everybody uh for
those great songs i went old school on
the uh swear job
someone in the chat did say the light
year uh dropped why your tickets dropped
and they did and i already got my ticket
for tomorrow or not tomorrow no next
week next week next week okay yeah
because it's coming out the 17th is that
thing yeah release date i got it next we
really owe thank you to david yoshimoto
who gave us 35 thank you
david's no love the content and the
frequency that's right thank you david a
lot of people have feelings about us
putting out up to four videos a day yeah
i appreciate you of course you like us
you want more of us david we like you hi
zeke they said to say hi zeke to my son
oh okay
your son i'm my son
real quick um this is an interesting
we're gonna pivot into we got a bunch of
obi-wan news yes rupert friend actor who
portrays the grand inquisitor
who's who's been dead yeah um the rupert
friend is not we're assuming we're an
inquisitor he uses his real teeth in the
in the show too right here this is real
skincare those are not prosthetics
because there's actual sharp teeth oh
wow
well he is english right he's got he's
got sharks
the news is rupert friend is scheduled
to be a guest on jimmy kimmel live this
friday and now the reason that's kind of
news actors uh singers whoever only
appear on these talk shows when they're
promoting something specific and now
this has led us to speculate does that
mean he's going to show up in tonight's
episode of obi-wan i think it's going to
be revealed that darth vader is actually
the grand inquisitor never was anakin
should we go to that live
tickets are available no hollywood
tickets are still going to be great we
ask questions hey are you alive because
you you know that like the disney plus
publicity department they're trying to
schedule these people strategically
right why would they have him
be doing promotion two episodes after
he's been killed
right
now it could also be a flashback we
could see maybe the origin of some of
these baby grand inquisitors baby
granite christmas with our little head
yeah yeah
biting his mother's nipple
oh get out of here
in kind of related star wars disney plus
news uh the cast of the mandalorian
teased a dark and even better season
three coming in early 2023 i think we're
getting that in february of next year uh
and one of my favorite cast members one
of my favorite people yes carl weathers
said that season three is fuller and has
a lot more happiness yeah he could be
describing a season he could be
describing livestock
for this season
fuller and has a lot more hair after a
recent hair transplant
carl weathers was jacked back in the day
um
he added it's so dense with so much
action but also character again could be
describing livestock
that's what i say about my girlfriend
so dead
but she gives me so much action and
she's full of characters
just kidding we're in a huge fight love
you
speaking of obi-wan kenobi we got a new
episode coming out tonight uh uh also a
new episode of his marvel coming out
tonight it's gonna be a crazy night for
everyone uh and this you know this
season of obi-wan kenobi so far has
shown us a very brutal version of darth
vader right uh and similar to like rogue
one where we saw how deadly and awful he
was and how he would kill everybody uh
and this is like the long disney
tradition of destroying families and
ruling with a terrifying level of
violence right he is a pure villain in
this series yeah uh so what do how do we
think they're going to go even farther
than what we saw we saw him murder
two family members and torture a woman
and drag her across torturing obi-wan
when you could have just killed him
instead
wants to inflict this pain i mean this
is a guy who whose story in the original
trilogy is one of redemption
or a long way from that yep remove my
helmet so i may look upon you with my
own heart do you think that's my whole
thing is now that the third sister has
already gone baby leia that means he's
gonna interact with her now this episode
right well maybe i mean that's the big
question like is
because to vader he does not know he has
children at all
and he doesn't even learn about luke
skywalker until after
a new hope when uh a boba fett figures
out it was a pilot named skywalker that
blew up the death star he was feeling
stuff remember he's like i feel
something but he was probably confusing
that with obi wan a little bit yes
he swipes away obi-wan he knows
obi-wan's not dead dead he knows he
disappeared when he kicks the rope some
great acting
right there uh but when he's attacked
when he flies into the trench run he's
like something's up nothing's screwy
with this pilot it doesn't make a lot of
sense so yeah him him interacting with
leia it would be i think they're going
to because she's gonna the third sister
is gonna bring her and be like obi-wan
wants this i got the baby i got the
child and he's gonna be like good oh god
oh god
he's gonna say that uh yogurt what is
this
some sort of taco seasoning
we were kind of talking around the
office like what how how is he gonna
ramp up his brutality even more one
thing that was brought up was leia's
adopted mother uh i forget bale's wife i
forget her name i'm so sorry
because we know that bail organa
survives we think to the trilogy yes the
original trilogy because when you were
saying when leia gives the message yeah
she mentions her father but i don't i
don't remember it being like past or
present in memory of my viewers father
it sounds like my father is doing this
so will you help us with this and i
don't know the lifespan of an
alderaanian i don't know how long they
live for well i mean for some it's in
the blink of an eye
it's very short it's very short
but what what brutal things do we think
we could see vader i mean he could kill
leia
i mean uh i i was thinking like we've
seen both in rogue one and certainly in
obi-wan so far a lot of good
hand-to-hand violence or force choke to
hand violence as it were like but we
have not seen that kind of like my death
star or my ship bombs your planet kind
of widespread chaos could we see some of
that yeah
i think we could see i mean i think
there needs to be more brutality from
vader obviously like we're they're
setting us up
it feels like what they're trying to do
is make the original trilogy even more
impactful by making it
even worse of a person yeah i also just
have this weird feeling like they teased
uh leia's kind of similar to her mother
try just got like her her uh
amidala padme like she used a handmaiden
or like one of her like servant girls to
like i wonder if there'll be like
another misdirection where like vader
thinks he's interrogating leia and it's
actually just another it's like a legend
yeah they're just always she's just like
that family is just always suffering for
his children
all over again
i got her body double killed i mean yeah
that is true
that's the only one we know how many
other how many other people have been
following yeah yeah because of these
people's insistence on you yeah it's so
soon that the
third sister got baby leia that i want
to believe that she took her and she's
not gonna show it to darth vader she's
gonna be like
i need i didn't she never revealed that
part of the plan to vader right it was
just that like i found
one baby leia is so
so curious and so knowledgeable i could
see her talking with third sister and
that's how we figure out third sister
was actually one of the young baby jedi
i think i think there's going to be
something crazy because by the time we
get to the original trilogy you know
there's that this line keeps kind of
popping in my head when vader's having
that when he shows up at that meeting
with grandma tarkin and the other ones
the one guy who he forced chokes it's
kind of like no one cares about your old
superstitions and blah blah blah blah
blah now there they wrote that line
before george knew what would become of
star wars but i think there's going to
be a moment when the emperor is going to
have to be like whoa whoa whoa vader you
have got to tone it down yeah yeah yeah
they're trying to win over the galaxy
right now with being like look we're
bringing order we're we're settling
things down
we're better for the galaxy and having
vader running around being a maniac and
killing people nearly is not a good look
i like that and so like if he is about
to go into a fallow period where he's
got to lay low we know these inquiry
inquisitors aren't hanging around till a
new hope right like at some point
they're going to get wiped out or
retired or whatever
like if there is something he does that
is so terrible that it leads to them
being like vader you gotta you gotta
keep it on the down low from now on
right well what if what i was thinking
is i kind of agree that like i don't
think third sister is gonna bring leia
directly to
vader and maybe vader and leia never
interacts what if this is the point
where she breaks off yes and because
again she's just trying to draw out
obi-wan she doesn't really believe in
any of this mission she's only using
vader for her own means and then we get
i think instead of the one on 1v1
obi-wan vader we get a
triangle standoff yes with riva obi-wan
involved a troll i said this true i said
this on wikileaks yes yes this is what
that's what i and that's my prediction
for this episode yeah which we're going
to get to later is that this is going to
be when riva goes off on her own this is
going to be the episode where there's a
skeptic you want to put money on it you
think vader's going to
lay off obi-wan's trail for right now go
back to mustafar
hang out chill relax yeah we're gonna
spend some time on most of our yeah more
time i think we might go back yeah okay
it's nice here this time of year
so i mean we ran a chat in the poll you
know uh 68 of you think we will see the
grand inquisitor
this episode it's not just later in the
series but this episode is coming up and
the dead body doesn't count it has to be
i do think he has to show up in this
episode for the kimmel interview to make
a lot of sense because otherwise it's
going to be or are you dead or i don't
know i'm not allowed to say i suppose
i'm dead i mean according to the tv show
i'm dead i could be dead but i could be
alive
but isn't that cheeky of me to say well
you sound like carl urban dude
well i think i like that idea and kind
of building off this kimmel speculation
not only grant and quiz are going to
show up this is going to be a big
episode for him okay right big now maybe
this full origin story we see a bunch of
flashback stuff maybe he just comes back
with a metal gut and he is swinging that
safer right and left and doing lots of
damage right i mean that would be a
great reveal in the inquisitor room
they're all sitting around fifth brother
third sister not getting along at all
boom doors open the grand inquisitor is
there he's like she stabbed me
back because they all think obi wan
right she told him yeah yeah yeah yeah
i caught this question in the chat and
this is a good question
when does vader learn about leia
uh
that that is a good question i i assume
he doesn't learn until much after he
learns about luke right because he was
he ever learned about it he didn't know
there were twins right i believe he just
knew that podman was he go to his grave
not knowing leia exists he knows
these are the questions that they talked
about in kenobi that they cannot do
another series on that's the that's the
stuff that the uh lucasfilms like is
constantly like we never actually
addressed this we can make another
freaking series out of the whole thing
so i think they're probably saving that
question for us
all right well you know what call in if
you know the answer
do you work at lucasfilms can you give
me a job
colin please come on the show you
cowards well
you face me in the octagon
you should you should have killed us
when you had the chance
i am what you've made me this side of
the table is while it out as they do as
they we are going to split this table in
half okay because the new episode of
kenobi drops tonight along with the
first episode of miss marvel big night
big night so we're ready to make some
predictions uh but we've decided to make
this a little friendly competition okay
yeah jessica and i will make two
predictions each for miss marvel and
then zach and tommy will make two
predictions for kenobi uh do you guys
want to go first do we want to go first
why don't we since we've been talking
about that let's go ahead well now i
will give you
though i brought it up you had made the
the prediction first on wikileaks do you
want to go with the troll yes i think we
are about to see a triad of conflict
riva
vader
kenobi
nice okay so you're calling that for
tonight yes uh i don't think that will
happen tonight that might be episode six
that might be what the series is
uh building up to i'm gonna predict and
this is an anticlimactic prediction
but that
we get no more interactions tonight
between obi-wan and vader obi-wan and
riva riva and vader those three people
do not interact
yeah okay and now here's a here's a
here's one that's going to absolutely
knock yourself your big swing we both
have to make a big swing prediction here
i think we're getting a musical sequence
tonight
i think we're getting some sort of
cantina babe
maybe a rebo cameo maybe just some i
think we're getting some sort of alien
that's a good one i like i like the
specificity of there here's what i'm
gonna go with it was one of my favorite
parts of the last few episodes
somebody's getting geeked out on spies
and by the way that reminds me friday
we're all going to be doing drugs no i'm
just kidding we're not going to be doing
this
chat is is correct yes so making sure we
know emma put in a super chat about it
vader learns about leia and return the
jedi there's a line where he's like you
have a sister or a sister some people
are saying
so they really took their time with that
they're like last last movie that we
know for sure thank you mr i think that
was george just like in his room like
what am i going to do for this third
part i don't know
so take the sum total of both tommy and
i's two predictions both our safe
predictions and our big swings and vote
in the chat
uh
the winner will be predicted and the
loser will be shamed thoroughly but now
moving on
we get our first episode of miss marvel
yes it's jandin's turn i called me and
brandon that oh a long time ago we call
ourselves tack
not even zamasu i like to call him
but yeah you said that i didn't like it
she likes james that's too much
do you like jandin or brunessica
brunessicas or a four-word scope called
zack but it's pronounced like czar
where's zach
t-z-a-c-h
okay so we got miss marvel coming out
tonight
and real quick to the room i want to ask
do we know if she gets her powers before
the show even starts we're starting with
her already having her powers i think
they should get something from the i
think she gets the bangle in the first
this is worth but this is worth the
prediction if you want to i think
think
that
she acquires her powers in the first
episode okay
and to add on to that
i think she gets
her powers
not from the bands oh not the bank
because i think the bagels i like in the
comics that the bengals were just
supposed to assist her uh her best
friend bruno created the bangles based
off of her old her parents old jewelry
and was like yo this will just help you
uh control your powers more i don't
think it's going to be giving her the
powers okay
so i think she's going to acquire her
her powers in the first episode but it
won't be is that your prediction
great uh my prediction is i think
there's going to be are you mad at me
i'm kind of i'm kind of
fueled by this little ratings change
they they maneuver yes they went we
talked about it yesterday they went from
tv pg to tv 14. i think there's going to
be a
spiderman ass esque uncle ben scenario
in this first episode where someone
close to her dies
oh i think it's gonna be a little heavy
wow a little heavier than we thought on
the first episode on the first episode
and that's something that drives her to
like fight crime to do better yeah you
know i'll be better oh i wish i wish i
could ah i wish i could top that i think
in like the fourth episode she'll kill
someone oh
she'll kill someone i think she'll hurt
someone
i think she'll hurt someone to the poor
yeah she's
struggling in the
[Laughter]
uh i think
uh
i think she falls in love with the first
episode oh
so we get a love interest confirmed come
first oh okay i like that
my second prediction it's a big one okay
i think we're gonna get a major cameo
all right like a major cameo from it
okay uh and then but it will be revealed
to the audience that that major cameo is
a squirrel
is this world
i was just kind of talking to you about
that so you kind of stole from me
no no no no i ran up to brandon
i literally went up to brandon said can
squirrels imitate powers and he said uh
some squirrels have powers jessica i
said okay cool and i ran away so
technically i did not skip this and we
we have heard none of us have seen the
episode but we have heard there is a
post-credits scene yeah the first
episode everybody stick around through
all those credits or maybe i don't know
if it'll be after portuguese credits or
whatever
uh but make sure you it's pretty
portuguese credits
it's portuguese it is pre-portuguese
credit
the long-standing portuguese credit
watch is over pvc i get i get to swear
but i want to do the special swear so
should we do it after okay okay thank
you uh aj stanton the other folks uh i
love you again
well someone gave 55 we have to thank
them
all the books thrown in super chats we
appreciate you oh happy birthday chrissy
josh chrissy
we wish you a happy birthday it's a
different christmas
[Music]
uh real quick and we're yeah we're gonna
back pocket that
swear because i think i think we have a
way of doing it real quick it's going to
be a special swear but um real quick we
want to plug g-fuel both tommy and i are
drinking g-fuel
sorry well here you know what oh
that problem has a solution um i'm
actually drinking some of that uh bahama
mama flavor i don't know what flavor
were you getting into i think i got some
miller light no all right it is i think
mine's just straight spices
shiny splash
they're ready to drink g-fuel hey john
nice cans
rtds ah we got the the link in this
video
okay john didn't like it you know here's
the thing we legit even on episodes we
don't talk about it we drink g-fuel a
lot of your rock stars uh we'll probably
tell by our dilated pupils manic energy
get a uh we shoot the show a little
later in the day sometimes we got up
early sometimes it's been a crazy busy
day we want to be able to bring the
energy on this show uh and so we often
pop some g fuel i gotta say it
definitely helps me if if we're uh
cruising and bruising through this
episode
but the nice thing about it i forgot to
bring them g-fuel also makes these
things just called hydration formulas
those are not caffeinated oh yeah those
just have like nice vitamins and a fun
flavor electrolytes those are nice maybe
you want to drink it at night before bed
or something like that i've had those
the flavors are good i gotta say
legit i've had a lot of energy drinks in
my life mm-hmm
these taste good these are really good
i'm just saying the flavors are nice on
the g fuel uh hit that link in the
description if you already are
purchasing g fuel if you're looking for
a new uh beverage in your life maybe you
want to try uh some energy drinks before
a workout or before heading to work in
the morning whatever if you use our link
we get a little we get a little
something something out of it you get a
ten percent discount we get a little
slice of happy it helps us keep this
show going everybody gets the g fuel
it's wins all around yeah
performance energy and extreme focus
extreme
speaking of uh extreme focus yeah tommy
time to focus up for mandatory fun oh
it says i'm in charge johnson if you can
please just tell us who gave 55 i
believe it's ruby or rudy put it up on
the super chat for us so we know i want
to thank
that person you know the numbers have
scrolled past thanks for hitting the
graphic it's mandatory fun i'm bouncing
around i'm all fueled up i'm all i got
six different kinds of g fuel in front
of me this is the segment that has swept
the nation it's pulling at 99.9 wow
and all i got to say is play it again
what they're asking for you to play it
again
oh you guys want me to play the graphic
again i don't i'm not your little puppet
boy ah we'll play it again when i say to
play it again
play it again
i needed that clarify
i mean all i can say is that when it
comes to this segment i like to feel
free and sometimes we play the graphic
times three hit it again
oh no now
everyone relax okay there's no more just
kidding play it for times four hit it
again
someone's stopping oh my god i can feel
the ratings starting to take a dive and
all i can say is hit it times five
play it again
wow
no no no we're not gonna do it again
yet
uh all right so
john just did it anyway john went rogue
well john you do that again i'm going to
send you to heaven play it for seven
we're not even m7
we gotta get to the segment
oh right so anyway
uh what are we talking about oh yeah
netflix has announced their geeked week
yes all this week oh this week they've
been doing good it's geeked week that
means it's time to have fun it's time to
explore your inner geekdom i've asked my
friends in the art department to make us
up a big board it's time for a good
old-fashioned geek week heat check yes i
redeem my swear you may redeem your
swear
can you give me a drum roll you guys
[Laughter]
now zeke knows how to spell it but
doesn't know how to say it
this one's playing great on podcasts
ruby larios gave 55 final closure on
that thank you dobson thank you ruby
ruby we thank you for your support now
okay
it's time for the geek week heat check
we're all gathered around the big board
bang
we're gonna decide which titles we're
excited for and we're gonna try and rank
them in order and you know what guys
this is my segment so i'm gonna go first
okay number one thing i'm excited for
you know it you love it oh baby
it's the sandman
the sandman neil gaiman's masterpiece of
a comic graphic novel series finally
being adapted
for the small screen
the phone the phone screen it's finally
not an audio drama for the bbc i can go
next because i don't think you guys
would have chose this and this was one
of the greatest
greatest shows to hit netflix for us
the suspenses killers yes
and that's arcade arcade
arcane based on like league of legends
but was like surprisingly popular
brandon's favorite game i played
what a great community that played
the series the writing was so good i'm
so excited for it arcane number two on
the heat check
sorry just wanted to get excited this is
that's what i think is going to do well
okay
okay i can't believe you chose
the russo bros okay
with the film called the gray man
hey it's got a little evidence in it
okay yes
you gotta you gotta do evans well i mean
oh whoa that's hey hey leave that i'll
give you that for later for later i will
say
ryan gosling making his return homeboy
hasn't made a movie since first man in
like 2017.
he has a lot to talk about but i i'm
excited for this it looks like a fun spy
thriller kind of a deal too many yeah
i've got it's unfortunately gray man's
gonna move oh oh we're so is our king
okay we're here i'm oh
resident evil it's my segment
i'm in charge i don't even know what
resident evil's about i will say i
haven't even seen one the trailer looks
great the trailer really does look good
all right jack okay so i want to i want
to pop in
here
featuring uh thor himself uh
luke hemsworth and um uh miles teller
recently seen on top gun maverick wow
this looks really fun it's kind of my
phone
is watching right now he put arcane
second to last don't come for me jessica
don't stick them on me please yeah um
spider head weirdly in the trailer no
spiders no spiders no spiders but a lot
of heads it looks great lots of heads
well what about the battles yeah
you got this umbrella you got that on
bro i think umbrella might be one
umbrella yes yeah umbrella and it's the
only of these it's the only uh known
property right it's the one we've seen
we've we've enjoyed the first two
seasons well resident evil's making the
the promotion from big screen movies
this should not be that low but i think
these should switch but also cuphead is
definitely at the bottom no it's not
classic
people love those little cuties yes
i want to say we don't have it
represented here there's a guillermo del
toro
anthology series that looks fun there's
a charlize throne uh kind of fantasy
movie oh i have a lot of fantasies about
there's a couple other like geeked week
is all about netflix promoting all of
their upcoming genre horror sci-fi
fantasy uh stuff superhero whatever um
these were the ones that kind of tickled
our fans yes now do we want to do we are
we disagreeing about the order do we
want to
reorder okay jessica put it in here you
want to put cuphead down here
resident evil i want to put spider head
underneath resident evil for sure
the only reason i want to do this is
because we are also cinephiles so we
know that these two look really great
but for nerd like nerd culture these two
are only standing because these two are
in no i am a scaredy pants so i do like
that i'm a little scared
well and and i will say resident evil it
the trailer looks great the effects look
really good no recognizable actors
that's a a total ruin uh thing but it
does make you concerned about the
overall quality i will say oh another
thing that's not uh live action one one
uh punch uh say that right that's the
manga one punch man one punch man
they're making a live action one of
those
cowboy bebop was a huge success
listen to me focus up thank you daschle
but we understand
that stranger things is part of geeked
week yes we get it but we've already
covered it we all know everyone loves
stranger things stranger things is way
if we can make the board 10 feet high
so don't write it in the comments yeah
there were a lot of shows you're writing
the comments you're gonna get made fun
of okay we're not we're sick we're sick
of stranger things don't write in we
love stranger things we're sticking all
the comments okay so
just stick with us here
uh oh oh two other things i'm sorry that
are not up here um midnight club yeah
mike flanagan who did the haunting
that looks kind of interesting oh also
new seasons for sweet tooth lock and key
couple other series is midnight club
continuation of midnight mass or is he
just real into making no it's a
different and it's also it's also not
about are you afraid of the dark which i
believe it was the midnight society oh
yeah lock and key is also really good
lock and key is very fun yeah well you
know this is a really cute list yeah i
think you've done a pretty good job oh
yeah but you're wrong about everything
okay uh you're forgetting about the best
one i didn't put it up there it's the
sleeper hit maybe
wednesday's coming back
tim
danny elfman christina
if they don't drop this on a wednesday
they're out of their minds what a missed
opportunity okay so this is our list i'm
not saying i agree with our list but i
do want to see what everyone in the chat
also has to say because i know
we all feel like we've been attacked
when they put our cane third from the
bottom
what are you excited about
what are you excited about let us know
in the chat let's get a poll up there
maybe we can't do an eight-pole maybe we
break him into fours because guys if you
guys are into this we'll cover it on the
break room yes that's the gift of this i
think there's a good chance that none of
this stuff maybe is is quite big enough
to justify us doing full breakdowns on
the new rockstars channel possibly we'll
see if some of them blow up but yeah we
could talk about these on the break room
especially if some of like uh resident
evil or sandman or or any of these other
series drop episodically weekly that'd
be really fun thing for us to talk about
if you let us know that that you're
interested me and brandon can do the
breakdown for arcane we play league of
legends and we love the show well that
sounds super fun
come here come here let's do this oh my
god
same shirt
all right hang on let's leave it on its
good side for the rest of the show they
paid for it
we've already been demonetized in norway
okay
all right i think i took your chair oh
that's okay here you go
mine is yours darling oh that's why
we're wearing the same shirt okay
heading back into it you should do these
more often these are very fun yes and
kudos to brandon in the full uh break
room art department which is brandon uh
for putting together that great visual
display
thriving art department and i would say
kudos to daschle and john for trying to
probably keep track of what was just
ten minutes of chaos so much effort
bless you both uh
oh
so someone's singing outside of our
studio right now if you're outside our
studio right now what are you singing
i was also just looking at the super
chat so what you guys said and someone
asked are you all seeing jurassic park
and i am tomorrow
i'm seeing it tomorrow i'm seeing it
tomorrow in 3d and i don't want to spoil
things but there are some pretty neat
jurassic park food tie-ins at carlos
junior then we're bringing snacks
one of those jurassic park
prime rib
monstrosities oh i guys i have a giant
uh
stomach capacity and i can do some truly
disgusting things on youtube
i might go one i might go one of each
i'm gonna go right down to jurassic park
lunches are pretty messed up i know
there's yeah so we also got a super chat
from another chrissy
who said there could be only one chrissy
she demands trial by combat what's a
birthday christy her birthday's in two
weeks uh it's too much of a coincidence
she's claiming there's a small scenario
wow
it's a real chrissy mess yeah
if you're watching and your name's
chrissy yeah we appreciate you uh wait
there's a few chrissy's in my past that
i don't i want to rescind that shout out
to you the chrissy from stranger things
i'm sorry
i love you yes but
going on speaking of chrissy speaking of
blonde white women eric voss broke down
that's a transition chrissy teigens like
say why that's a true segway
breakdown eric vaz's new video where he
discusses the possibility of other mcu
characters being avatars for gods
including black panther um as bass and
namor as it's um
so uh let's go ahead and look at the
clip
[Music]
okay
hear you
and we're back
did you guys hear uh
i know that there's a lab well just um
uh yeah a quick recap right uh the clip
we were gonna play is eric kind of
looking at all the different gods that
we could see visible um in the different
shots we've seen from thor also just
real quick we're very close to the 300
uh swear jar limit somebody's got about
19 bucks in their pocket we're only
going to put the audio back on
the audio you're about to hear might get
uh real right um but uh and so we were
just saying combined with like what
we've what we've kind of uh discerned
about neymar and black panther 2 and how
we might be connected to like mayan gods
um like what do we think about the gods
as they're going to be depicted in four
levels something boss brings up in the
breakdown of this clip is that like in
marvel comics there's a thing called the
pantheon of gods which kind of zeus i
think it kind of oversees it a little
bit but it's all the different gods from
the different religions they they send a
representative they check in to make
sure like hey we're making these little
dumb humans do what we want right that's
cool that's cool uh and they've brought
up this idea of avatars right we we've
always known that black panther was an
avatar boss or bastet
uh and then you know moon knight showed
us how they have avatars for gods so
what this film could kind of open up and
lead into like with black panther or
wakanda forever is that neymar is
actually an avatar for this mayan god
uh this like kind of jaguar god and that
may be
uh the sinking of uh atlantis had to do
with like the meteor hitting the the uh
vibranium meter meteor hitting in africa
causing like earthquakes around the
world and sinking this city maybe that's
what caused the conflict between the
wakandans and that's a goddamn [ __ ]
great idea
oh we said that we said three hundred
dollars the jar is broken right the jar
is broken
can you break it that's not the journey
we said four hundred dollars the jars
okay look there's a little square hog
today
oh no you guys got tommy's impression of
this
is this what you wanted because you got
it
okay so oh my god dear lord you can't
take g fuel during the show get this
jeep away from us use our code
to say yeah you didn't see tommy do a
straight line
before we start that's not g fuel oh no
it's spice
but what i was gonna say was i don't
think i agree with boss thinking that
those are the avatars for the gods
because mainly out of straight
irritation i would get knowing that
black panther was the vessel for best
i'd be like it could have gone to anyone
it could have gotten anyone i like the
idea that maybe he got it because he had
to drink herb going into the sand but
i'm like no
no i'm like i don't think bass would
choose black panther or
specifically t'challa i think bass would
choose someone else
you know black panther kind of
established that like the people decide
who's going to be or there's the ritual
of fighting to decide who's going to be
but no one in the black panther yeah uh
hero but his acknowledgement of black
panther during civil war when he was on
the bench when he talked to scholars
yeah uh was just so like this is our god
you think he'd also mention like i'm
also the vessel for her you have to
explain everything
i want them to explain it's in the world
but maybe maybe they do use different
language but referring to the same thing
i do kind of i don't know that they'll
go this way but i really like this idea
just that like in the marvel cinematic
universe or all the marvel characters
right we see some you could get your
powers from gamma radiation you could
get your powers from super soldier serum
and i like them expanding out or like or
like a weird you know not weird a god
type character could give you your
powers and that could be multiple just
like there's multiple mutants there's
multiple people that have taken super
soldiers here i like the idea that
there's multiple people that can be
these like
it introduces a different type of
consequence right like the the the
consequence of having the gamma
radiation make or some sort of energy
make you empowered is there's usually a
negative side effect to it right in when
a god uses you as their avatar in the
mcu not in real life i i have never been
an avatar for a god
but uh a lot of people say that for a
while mr queen was in charge of me
i i did that's when he got that piercing
i did go to a cult that worshipped mr
clean for a while we were called
cliniacs but uh kleenongs uh but anyway
i think that yeah when the gods take
control and and give someone powers they
expect
their
them to do things for them they
basically become their errand boys right
like
well and
not to uh make it to irl too but like it
could kind of help justify a different
actor
having the black panther mantle right
because like avatars can can pass on but
then a new avatar is selected right like
we know that happened with moon knight
right like um uh so maybe that is a way
to justify somebody a character that is
not t'challa yeah having that power i
don't think that it's uh insane or
ignorant but i
it sounds offensive but it's like i just
don't think i can see with t'challa as
black panther but i could see it with
someone else namor doing it i could see
that i could see him being the chosen
one and then because nammer's also like
is he good is he bad yeah it kind of
flexes so i could see
that one i just can't see the charlie
one i just i don't want it i don't want
it's too much and now real quick we're
pretty sure this giant pantheon of gods
is what's the term brandon in the marvel
term for
all the gods the pantheon of gods okay i
got it right
but
we're pretty sure a lot of them are
getting introduced just to get killed by
the god butcher it's right there in his
title he butchers gods that's right
how many or what if he's a personal
butcher for the yeah what do you need to
fillet what do you want
i've actually got a i got a whole lamb
that i can cut up today who wants chops
who wants money he's actually just in
the bronx at his own
who ordered the prime rib i got prime
rib going out to zeus okay
where he's the god of butchers all
butcher's prayed
but we're pretty sure he's gonna kill a
bunch of these characters yeah
for real which of these new ones i know
jessica you've been standing for a while
hercules is going to make it out
um other maybe new characters we meet in
thor 11th under who don't get killed who
then can exist in the future
um
i hope they could like kill artemis i'm
just thinking about other greek gods
because that scene where they're like
it's clear i i was like it's pausing the
trailer the new clip they so it's right
when he got naked thor when they ripped
off his clothes he put it on he's
fighting the guards so it's like i feel
like someone that leads the army for the
gods will probably die does that make
sense like the uh who's the it's not
artemis uh who's the god of war aries so
if it's someone like aries dying oh
interesting they might want to kill off
aries because isn't that also a figurine
wonder woman yeah maybe it's a little
too complicated to have multiple aries
characters well they can do a quick
little hey oh
is there any chance and am i getting uh
too out of uh my depth here that like
the eternals will be included in this
yeah maybe an eternal world the
internals aren't here they're off
they're also not really technically guys
is what if we get a little harry styles
cameo but they're already on the ship so
that he has to kill angelina jolie and
the rest of them well what if they just
show up i mean
it's presumably some time has passed
yeah they could show they could show up
the ones that are not sucked up by uh
aeroshem and
gore i like that line in the trailer
where gore literally harry styles sorry
the prompter just says harry styles
question mark um i like the part in the
trailer where gorlo god butcher's like
you're different to thor like you're
different you care about people but i'm
still going to kill you
the norse gods are kind of already dead
yeah thor and then that's it right
because loki's gone
[Applause]
might just be floating in space we don't
know if she's gone gone what if he just
goes jordan he's dead frank is dead poor
jane what if he just goes immediately
for jen because he has the powers of our
god now so he's just like girl come over
here let me slice it it might also be
funny if he just ignores the norse ones
because he's like yeah you guys aren't
really guys
um oh a couple of uh polls we want to uh
touch on so we asked everybody which of
the geeked week netflix properties
you're most excited about
kind of running away with it umbrella
academy yeah
yeah with sandman actually has a decent
percentage wednesday adams third place
and then a lot of people just said other
that's probably like the other was 26
and i know that's our case okay he cares
about our games
i will say there's been somebody that's
commented on every new rockstars video i
think for over a hundred days that
they're gonna keep making this comment
until we break down arcane
um
jessica yeah maybe maybe
it's her avatar i don't know um whoever
that is if you're watching now i don't
know that we're gonna break it down but
we might talk about it on this show they
did ask if we're gonna do we break down
jurassic park someone else probably will
we probably will i'll i'll make this
easier
give us two thousand dollars we'll break
down our time for you and don't give it
to the super chat venmo me personally
and i'll break it down for you and
here's how it goes welcome back to new
rockstars i'm tommy bechdel today we're
breaking down our cane get a wife
oh my god
stop stop going after that kitty
accident
he's the he's the bad twin i'm the good
guy
i'm here for arcane he's against
anything i love yeah
[Applause]
shout out a couple of the super chatters
thank you td jones yeah standing for
mandatory fun we appreciate you t.d
jones yes aj stanton thoughts on the
miss marvel shorts i haven't seen it
is that was that like a final trick
on
disney plus oh i didn't see it i haven't
checked it out okay
we'll we'll watch it aj stan and then
we'll have some thoughts thank you uh
aiea zoupay saying it took me until now
to realize that vader's helmet is
supposed to resemble a hood from his
cape over his mouth sound like that
little back part yeah
the overhead little jedi so can we talk
about jedi robes they're just robes
they're robes what do you mean well like
there's plenty of people walking around
star wars with little robes on also
empire if you're gonna send
stormtroopers to look for a jedi give
them a picture of what the jedi looks
like that's a good point they were
sitting in the truck with him that's a
good point give them a picture yeah that
part that's probably unbelievable to me
like they give them a pic they're like
we're searching for a jedi okay i cut
you off what were we saying okay no oh i
thought you were the mean twin
so it's okay someone would be mean
so someone be me i don't want to be the
mean twin oh my god fine i'll do it
fine i'll do it what's another 17 more
years invincible so um i also think it's
well the mole doesn't really know what
he looks like because he's a mole person
he doesn't have the mo i'm talking about
the stormtroopers
with findings
trooper is famously not good at their
jobs because they've got bad management
yeah it's been made clear in this series
and it's a conscripted army i mean a lot
of these guys aren't volunteers
some of them like it what if they what
if one of them didn't know that was him
and just was like i think i think our
friend shane a friend of the show friend
of the comedy community shane hartline
played one of those storms he did he did
and i think he knew and i think he
sandbagged it i think he's on the side
of the rebellion and he did it on fire
classic uh clip from the batman animated
series where uh henchman opens the door
sees batman and just closes the door
it's like nothing's in there yeah keep
walking i think shane shane said he
wants the rebellion to succeed he wants
the jedi
thank you shane for all your hard work
uh undermining the empire we appreciate
you body if you mix this with the this g
full got me crazy got me cracked out
right now but if you mix it with vodka
would it be a vodka red bull i think we
can recommend that
yeah i think it would be caffeine and
alcohol i don't know
[Applause]
can we give this cocktail that you
definitely shouldn't try at home a fun
name like what's the nickname for
alcohol and g g-fuel
disaster
g-diesel oh that's a good one
i'm trying to think of a superhero
themed for and uh
you'll feel like a new god
new god new god i like that i like g
diesel still that one's a good one
that's a good i think it's uh i think we
maybe give it a break room thing maybe
it's a maybe it's a break room boiler
maker oh i'm gonna make a cook book
eventually and then you'll be able to
guys call in if you want to get caught
yeah that's right hit that 1-800 number
um i was also going to say we're we're
testing out we want a term that we can
use you know mt has uh welcome back nerd
babies uh eric vos always does uh
welcome back to new rockstars we want to
term that we can use for the break room
audience we floated and i kind of like
this one roomies welcome back roomies
yeah roomies come on you're here with
the roomies on the zoomies um but if if
you've got a better idea for for what to
call the the broad break room audience
throw that in the chat we'd love to have
you oh that's a good one someone said
thanos for the drink title
famous because the anus
asking for that yellowstone breakdown
we're going to get into the taylor
sheridan universe
there's only 16 yellowstone-based shows
so i think we'll start breaking them
down that's a full channel just breaking
down those shows that's a full youtube
channel
i got it welcome back to new rockstars
i'm tommy bechtolden today we're going
to break down the yellowstone universe
it's called this get a life you losers
come on okay you're taking all our moms
and dads around nobody's like zeke is
watching dude
sorry zeke do you like yellowstone if
you do get a life you lose damn helen
mirren's gonna be on the show all right
i'm helen mirren's watching yeah this
one's for you get away you losers
a treasure thank you guys thank you for
all the also the the breakies the break
rumors the
which god i hope is a buffalo reference
[Music]
i think i'm gonna i'm gonna steal the
break next
this is pretty great
uh certainly when we're g fueled up uh
we get pretty breakneck over here we
need to uh we need the rumors uh there's
a lot of good ones we'll look over these
and maybe if one kind of sticks one
feels right we'll start using it because
we want to be able to refer to all of us
as a collective group uh but speaking of
a collective group we appreciate you we
appreciate everybody that was chatting
today appreciate all those super
chatters um we got out some really nice
fun profanity
both the written and the verbal kind
we'll be back tomorrow we'll have
watched both obi-wan and miss marvel
we hope it comes out before break room
we'll also talk about that tomorrow's
show is going to be loaded a lot to talk
about and that's all building up friday
uh thursday and friday we'll have a lot
going on friday again we'll be nuts yeah
it'll be a while it'll be crazy we'll
watch an episode of arcane yeah and then
you guys will love it i swear tomorrow
will be loaded and i'll be loaded for
tomorrow yeah
[Applause]
it's not going to work we're not going
to use it all i got left is break room
later
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you